después de varios días en los que se
pensó que la ofensiva para tomar o
dehesa este puerto sobre el mar negro
era inminente la situación ha vuelto a
calmarse más o menos hemos estado
haciendo un recorrido en la tarde de hoy
especialmente por esta preciosa parte
central de esta ciudad y todas están
militarizada está llena de barreras todo
está listo para un posible ataque sin
embargo hemos visto cómo la ciudad vive
y hay muchísimas personas siguen
viviendo en ella a pesar de esta tensión
y el temor que muchos tienen estamos
aquí con katrin martel que es lingüista
y traductora de varios idiomas y como
muchos ha decidido quedarse
katrin porque ha decidido quedarte para
mí ellos de eso es un lugar muy especial
es mi ciudad natal y yo no quiero salir
de aquí yo voy a quitarme aquí para
ayudar a la gente que sigue viviendo sus
vidas normales ayudar a los ancianos
hacer todo lo posible para terminar la
guerra
el ambiente es muy raro porque hay mucha
calma hay muchas calles solas en algunos
sectores en otros hay muchísima gente
que conocen las sensaciones no desa en
este momento qué piensas tú qué puede
pasar ahora nosotros estamos mucho más
tranquilos que al empiezo de la guerra
la ciudad está bien protegida y nosotros
tenemos la confianza en nuestro ejército
y nuestro gobierno
una última pregunta y es esta es una
ciudad cultural de
audio cráneo una las ciudades culturales
que ha pasado con todo ese movimiento
cultural
a las personas los músicos y artistas
tienen una posición muy seria contra la
guerra hacen todo lo posible para que
más personas saben de la situación en
ucrania hablan con los periodistas de
otros países haciendo reportajes por la
televisión en esta ciudad de hablando
con varios habitantes todavía existe la
esperanza de que algo cambia última hora
y que no haya un ataque y que al menos
no se destruya esta ciudad que es un
tesoro no solamente para los ucranianos
sino para los rusos que la duran también